Nigerians are heading to the polls for
the general elections
the race has two main contenders current
President Muhammadu Buhari from the
ruling or progressive Congress and his
challenger the former vice president at
eco abu bakar from the opposition
People's Democratic Party president
rouhani came into office in 2015 with
major campaign promises like fighting
corruption and crushing extremist group
Boko Haram four years later President
Buhari spike against corruption has
received accolades and praise from all
over the world except at home where many
remain disappointed every century was
revealed that Nigeria has the world's
highest concentration of people living
in poverty distress all right now it's
quite soft and almost confessed in sorry
hide these are getting worse
people are finally so difficult to it's
even worse than I did
as for Boko Haram not much has changed
if anything the terrorist group as well
as other militant groups continue to try
mujeres strongest opposition Antico Abu
Bakr is promising economic prosperity
he's assuring Nigeria's that if he is
voted in as president unemployment and
poverty would be a thing of the past
promises Nigerians are used to bury I'm
sort of Woodson because of the empty
promises you understand those things
that sellers they're gonna do to help
the nation so a compassionate to the
country they are not doing it what are
you talking about let us think of the
basic they said they will do something
on what are they done up till now it's
easier for them to make promises you
know that the other day an order to
fulfill it so the race for Nigeria's top
job appears to be a yes battle between
the two big parties but experts agree
that popularity strong financial support
as well as endorsement from Nigeria's
so-called political Godfather's seem to
be the main path towards achieving
presidency in the country so exactly as
its Godfather's and how important are
they
Godfather's don't usually run for office
themselves but many believe they are the
ones who decide the election winners and
losers they have political sponsors who
use money and influence to win support
for their preferred candidates their God
zones it is believed are not always
selected for their political aptitude
but rather on their ability to repay and
enrich their Godfather after the war a
lot of Nigeria's were impoverished so
there were a few who made money so they
noticed any young man who had the you
know the flair for politics
[Music]
food supports those ones under some
conditions so it's like investing
business
Emma feet in spite of all this there's a
third crop of political hot pools that
are challenging the establishment 71 of
them the most prominent among these
hopefuls are characterized by their
willingness to challenge Nigeria's two
party establishment and by their age a
social media campaign Duran in May 2016
under the hashtag not too young to run
succeeded in lowering the required age
of the president from 42 certified while
the two main candidates who Haryana siku
a both older than 70 Nigeria itself is a
country where more than 60% of the
population is less than 25 years old
other campaigns have also been pushing
for people to get involved in this
election by signing up to votes as a
result of this and following 14 million
new voters already start to vote in this
election many of them will be first-time
voters